I never logged before so this is funny I
hope I'm doing this right I moved to Los
Angeles from Oklahoma a few years ago
and I just had a really deep desire to
be a director but was utterly terrified
to break into such a male-dominated
industry I was very lucky to get an
internship at BuzzFeed and after about a
year total of begging to be on the
creative to you they finally let me I
get to go around the country and direct
videos which is an absolute dream and so
this weekend I'm going to Chicago while
I'm there I'm going to be vlogging five
pieces of advice about what it's like to
be a woman breaking into a
male-dominated field thanks hi honey I'm
procrastinating packing for Chicago so
instead I'm going to do my first vlog my
first piece of advice is to trust your
vision it means trusting the vision that
you have for yourself and for your
future for years I could not call myself
a director because I felt like an
imposter I pink hair I'm very young you
know I'm not a dude after a while I was
like this is really silly because I am a
director and that's what I do and once I
started trusting that vision and really
believing it other people started
believing it it starts with you
believing it first and trusting in that
and then the rest will follow
okay will song come back for me because
I probably hate back good morning from
Chicago I'm up very early getting ready
for my shoot number two and two take
care of yourself first just because you
are a woman perhaps in a male-dominated
field that doesn't mean that you can't
be a woman on set I'm gonna tissues here
is usually how I'm usually very sweaty
and disgusting but whenever there is a
break I usually do go to the restroom
and reapply my lipstick I used to be a
little embarrassed about that kind of
stuff but not anymore whenever I travel
I bring my whole skincare routine you
know I bring my WIPs my own use you know
this made me feel more confident and I
think it makes me a better director
whenever I show up feeling good whatever
it is that you like you should do that
you should take care of yourself because
those are going to yield the best
results
number three plan ahead unfortunately I
think as a woman if you are not fully
buttoned up it's very easy for other
people to assume that you are under
qualified do the research do your
homework take the detailed notes
whatever it is you need to do to go
above and beyond don't ever give anyone
a reason to say that you don't know what
you're doing because you do I wanted to
get my fourth piece of advice which is
to be vocal and I think this one can be
tough for women especially me someone is
speaking over you or seem rolling a task
that you were assigned to it is okay to
say hey excuse me I actually wasn't
finished speaking if you do that in like
a polite professional manner and they're
offended by you speaking for yourself
that's not your problem because if you
don't speak up for yourself who's gonna
I just got home from Chicago I am
running on three hours of sleep actually
very surprised that my skin looks this
good but I wanted to give you my final
piece of advice number five would be to
listen well I personally have kind of a
bad habit of walking around a little bit
like I know what I'm doing and I don't
need help from anybody you never know
when someone else's idea is going to
help you or teach you a lesson or make
your idea even better and remember it's
okay to say now listen first and then if
someone's idea doesn't align with what
you want then you can say no I would
just encourage always being humble and
open-minded because no one's ever gotten
very far in this world all alone this
all comes straight from my mother these
are all things that she has told me I
want to leave this video just hoping
that some of what I've said could help
at least one other young woman in the
world who has big dreams and wants to
break into some sort of male-dominated
industry or any industry whatever it is
you want to do I hope some of that get
emotional and I did not think that would
happen
keep empowering one another keep being
nice keep listening well and keep being
the boss ladies that you are good bye
this has been very fun this has been a
great first logging experience so cut
[Music]